we've been telling you right here on fox
about the escalating tensions along the
ukrainian-russian border but what is the
history of the conflict and friendship
between these two nations and how do we
get to this point where all-out war
could be days away here's a quick
history lesson
rich soil and a defensive barrier that's
what ukraine means to russia but the
historic conflict dates back to the 9th
century when scandinavian vikings moved
their capital to kiev in ukraine a
legacy president vladimir putin often
invokes when arguing that ukraine is
bound to russia now russia was attacked
for centuries and eventually overrun in
the 13th century the vikings relocated
in and around moscow and russia didn't
have a leg to stand on it was completely
indefensible they had no mountains no
deserts few rivers
flash forward 18th century peter the
great and empress captain the great same
last name expanded the russian empire by
taking ukraine again
russia had its buffer zone now they
could defend themselves against attacks
from the baltic sea
that changed in 1917 the aftermath of
the russian revolution the ukrainian
national movement for self-determination
emerged and the ukrainian people's
republic was declared at last ukraine
got its independence
flash forward to world war ii
fearlessly and ferociously fighting with
the red army the ukrainians helped beat
back the nazis losing at least eight
million soldiers more than 5.5 million
civilians how were they rewarded the
soviet union swallowed up the entire
nation
it stayed that way until 1991 when the
soviet union collapsed
ukraine broke away and once again was on
its own
russia kept a watchful eye on its
breakaway brother until they overthrew
their pro-russian leader and reached out
to the west with the goal of joining
nato
[Applause]
that crossed the line for putin he took
back crimea by force in 2014 60 years
after was given to ukraine claiming the
russian-speaking people asked for help
now vladimir has virtually surrounded
ukraine as the people in the world wait
to see if they will try and take the
nation
back standing their way is 150 000 up to
250 000 ukrainians who know how to fight
especially my next guest vitaly
klitschko did not need that history
lesson he's a ukrainian citizen who
brought great fame and acclaim to his
country as the heavyweight champion of
the world before retiring with his belt
in 2013. he always had a fierce national
pride never backing off from conflict
especially now as the mayor of kiev a
job he's held since 2014 is he ready
perhaps for his toughest opponent to
date the entire army of russia let's ask
him he joins us now from the ukraine uh
welcome vitali great to see you
good to see you also
uh mr mayor
does this remind you of the moments
before a fight when you have the robe on
you and you're walking into a ring you
knew a fight was inevitable do you have
that same feeling now
no no no no it's no way it's a total
different story
uh it's not sport it's uh hard reality
it's uh if somebody 10 years ago told
the big part of ukraine will be occupied
crimea occupied from russian
danes lugansk will be occupied from
russian forces and more than 13 000
people 14 000 ukrainian
died in this war it's nobody believe in
that but today is reality today is
reality because
more than 100 uh
russian soldiers stay in the board of
ukraine and everybody in the world
talking about possible aggression
against ukraine we are peaceful people
we are peaceful country we're not
aggressive to anyone but
if
somebody
the uh star
make aggression against ukraine we have
to defend our independency we have to
defend our country we have to defend our
families
it's not sport
uh it's uh
it's not joke uh it's uh everybody
everybody pay attention in many people
in ukraine very nervous
if you listen to vladimir putin he says
ukrainians are one with russia they
should be one with russia we have a long
kinship together uh this is false this
this reach out to the west so therefore
i'm going to almost do you a favor by go
ahead and taking the capital what do you
say to that russian sentiment
the reason of this conflict because
vladimir putin want to rebuild soviet
empire
have vision to make
russian empire and ukraine yes of course
one of the
largest countries in europe uh have to
be
as part of his vision in his empire
right we was in soviet union we don't
want back to ussr we see our future
as
modern european democratic country
uh vitaliy a couple of things i read
that you're very disappointed the way
the germans are acting uh very
disappointed the way the germans are
acting they gave you 5 000 helmets they
might even be charging you for it
they're not letting arms go through
their country what's your reaction to
the german's lack of support
first of all i want to say uh thank you
very much for
the
united states united states delivery the
defensive weapon for ukraine is very
important to us for us
to have support political support
and financial support from united states
what
the germans amounts about 5 000
is helms
joke his joke but
by the way thank you for the helms yeah
thank you for the helmets you said you
can what are you going to send me next
pillows vitaly i have uh are you there's
a report that there was a conversation
between the president's biden and
zielinski at which time president biden
says get ready for impact the invasion's
going to happen and they're going to
sack
the capital you're the mayor of that
capital if that is in fact the case
what do you say to people who say that
that you guys are going to get run over
um
actually
we are also responsible for for self
for
municipal defense for
civilian defense in our country and all
uh mans actually ready to
be
a soldier to defend our country i don't
i am not in well involved in the
conversation between united states
president and president of ukraine
that's why i
can't give a commenter about the
conversation and uh lastly uh there's a
report that just says if they come for
your capital that you're going to fight
too are you physically going to get out
there with the ukrainian army and fight
to repel the russian forces
as a former soldier i promise to defend
my country and i have to keep my
promising yes of course i have to defend
i have to defend my city and
defend my future defend my family
i hear you uh vitaly klitschko uh it's
tenuous time in the ukraine i'm sure the
the people of kiev are glad you're in
charge thanks so much for joining us
today
thank you for support thank you you got
it hey sean hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else